SEVEN ON A PLAY THAT. YEAH THAT
ONE DOESN'T WORK RIGHT. YOUR
YEAH OKAY. GOOD OF THE RULE
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MAY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER PLEASE BE ADVISED
AN AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED. OUR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTEND
THIS HEARING OR ENCOURAGE WEAR
MASK AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES
MUST OFFER REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT THIS HEARING. VIOLATION
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE WALDRON BENNETT.
BONTA FLORA FONG. LEE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RUBIO STONE
WE HAVE CORN WE HAVE A QUORUM-
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
REMOVE ITEM NINE FROM THE
CONSENT AGENDA AND VOTE ON IT
SEPARATELY VERY GOOD AT THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER- IS OUR
EMOTIONAL THE REMAINDER THE
CONSENT MOVED MOVERS SECONDED BY
MR LEE. A MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE WALDRON BENNETT. BENNETT I
BONTA. BONTA HI FLORA FONG FONG
I LEAD THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE STONE. PASS
THE MOTIONS PASSED A IS OUR
MOTION ITEM NUMBER NINE YEARS A
CLOSE REQUEST FOR A BI SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN. OVER MR LEE SECONDED BY
MR BENNETT I MISS CERTAIN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY
AYE WALDRON BENNETT. BENNETT I
BONTA. BONTA HI FLORA FONG FONG
I LI LI I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS. MATHIS
NO RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STONE.
MOTIONS PASSED AND I THINK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE ALL REMAIN
HERE FOR A FEW MINUTES
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN. THANK YOU
ALL. OKAY FOR EXAMPLE THE TAX
LAST NIGHT YEAH VERY GOOD DEVON
GOOD TO SEE YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE ON THE CONSENT I. STONE
HI- SO IMMERSED ON THE URGENCY
BECAUSE REQUEST FOR AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY SIX STONE HI. THANK YOU
MICHELLE. THIS RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. SO DID YOU GET ANY BREAK
DURING THE PER.